All right, guys. So here is the example number one for the for this strategy. Okay, so now look at this, we have been bullish here, then we have been bearish, but we respected the the OTE level, which is the 0.705 and 0.79 level. Okay, after that, what we did have was this shift in market structure, right?
And then we had marked out this OB here, and then we got a perfect reaction from this level. Okay, so now our narrative, we know that price could be going up from here. Okay, because we have been respecting the PD areas right here, the discounted zone.
We also had a shift in market structure. We also been creating high, high, high, low, high, high, high, high, high, high, high, high, high, high, high, high, high, and then we have this lower, lower, lower, high, lower, low, right? So if I, if I had like another, a lower, low here, then I would consider the trend to be bearish. But since we have this here, we are still bearish, a bullish, sorry. Okay, so now look at this, guys, we have this bearish candle, right?
And this candle, the body of this candle, closed above the body of this bearish candle. So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna mark out the body of this candle. Let's go back to 15 minutes.
And as you can see, we are now in the auto block. So this is the structure that I want to see broken. And as you can see, the body closed above this level.
So now these consecutive bearish candles also took out this liquidity here. You see this low here, price, the auto block took out this liquidity.
So now we have these consecutive bearish candles, right? So now there's also this free value gap. Okay, so now that is a perfect entry. And also look at this, we have a breaker block here, lower, low, lower, high, lower, low.
And this is what I mean when the auto block and breaker block are in alignment with each other. You look at the, look at the closing price and the open price of this candle, right? It just goes back down and the size is the same here.
Now you can simply look for a long position here, put your stop right below the slope and go for one to two. Cool. And as you can see, the market structure shift happened during kills on ours.
Okay, that happened during London session. So let's see what happens. We filled in this really gap. We had our entry. The body was respected here. The bodies did not close below this auto block. And let's see how this plays out.
We hit our take profit level. And if I play this through, you can see the price is still going. And this happened today. Literally it happened today. It happens every single day, guys.
Okay, the main thing is that you have to identify the auto flow. If you can successfully do that, you are like in the right direction to become extremely profitable.
So I hope this example was somewhat educational. I'll give you guys another example.